ماذا نعرف عن المجموعة التي تقول
إنها تقف وراء الهجوم على القاعدة الجوية
في
العراق؟ إنها مجموعة إيرانية خلفية.
عنوان المقاومة الإسلامية في العراق هو
عنوان شامل يشمل نوعًا ما
الكثير من مجموعات الميليشيات الشيعية المختلفة
التي لديها  لقد نمت
قوتهم حقًا على مدار العقد الماضي أو نحو ذلك، وقد
هاجموا عدة مرات قواعدنا في العراق وسوريا
143 مرة منذ أن هاجمت حماس يوم
7 أكتوبر، وهناك الكثير من الهجمات التي قاموا
بتكثيفها، لماذا لأن وكلائهم
أم إيران، لذلك فإن
بصمات إيران موجودة في كل مكان، ما نعرفه
من رئيس البلدية المحلي الذي كان قادرًا على
مشاهدة هذا الهجوم على قاعدة الأسد
الجوية أم أنه رآه من مسافة بعيدة
وقال إنه رأى الكثير من الصواريخ
القادمة لبعضها  تم اعتراضها
من قبل أنظمة الدفاع الصاروخي ولكن بعضها
تجاوز ونفهم من
البنتاغون أن هناك إصابات
أه بين أفراد الخدمة الأمريكية لا نعرف
عدد الأفراد ولا نعرف
مدى خطورتها وهذه قاعدة أه جوية مشتركة
عراقية  العسكريون هناك أيضًا
ويقول الجيش العراقي إن واحدًا على الأقل
من أفراد خدمتهم أصيب
في هذا الهجوم، لذا يبدو هذا حقًا
وكأنه تصعيد، وعندما
تأخذ الأمر بالتزامن مع ما حدث
في دمشق هذا الصباح، فإنك تحصل على
بمعنى أن هذا التصعيد الذي
يتحدث عنه الجميع هو ما قد
نشهده هنا